[Music]
everybody going in wake up early in the
morning press play and let's get it in
cause we rocking with the fighter
[Music]
it just got a lot more wrinkly in here
you guys are surprised because i still
got it
still [ __ ] popping
now this is gonna hurt it's gonna hurt a
little bit do you only drive with the
windows down
because your face is
i want to talk about your weather face
yeah you get a little skinny here bro
yeah you skinny you know what the diet
is what stress
i was in dallas i went to dallas do a
little louder with crowder
okay and um was it louder it was louder
you faced on me for now hold on
hold on what's going on with your face
are you talking about this oh i dip now
i dip now hey have you ever seen it's
been mad for something yeah it should
hey have you ever dipping while you're
podcasting now oh yeah welcome
welcome to the show
about it room did get darker you got
darker you got your
neighbors on i was like this is a very
black show
it was me just all black guys yeah yeah
friend that was doing this
i'm not gonna lie he looked good looking
like the [ __ ] guy yeah you hit it you
fit in
he does a lot of people think he's you
know he he
likes mine women yeah that's true
yeah what they what it likes black women
it's true first this is well done
well documented yeah now um well i'm a
little skinny because
got to dallas and all of a sudden it was
a blizzard you understand oh yeah
couldn't find a car to rent or anything
else
and then i got to my hotel room and
while the power went out
and there was no heat yeah not even
dallas it was on it was the outskirts
and then there was no heat
and then i uh and then so i i had to eat
pringles in the dark
and all the restaurants were closed and
i found a mcdonald's don't eat
mcdonald's
do you even no he doesn't eat i don't
but i never was because i was starving
and there were 36 cars in line because
the only thing it was the only thing
open
what'd you get daddy so daddy didn't get
mcdonald's daddy went home oh yeah too
long away i'd rather starve
and then i tried to do this i tried i
was like you know what you're hungry
you're in the dark
i'm going to meditate oh yeah oh yeah
watch because your stomach goes you know
what
we're not hungry yeah watch watch
watch how it went i went like this
[ __ ] it [ __ ] it starving meditating hi
cat
oh wait chin what up bro this is good a
few things that uh
have you ever seen austin powers i'm
like number two and he's dr evil it's
like you were
frozen and then you come back and i'm
like well the business
we made 300 million a year we could make
up to three thousand dollars
let's do them for one million dollars
you look great
thank you buddy things are a little
different cat hasn't only fans now and
she doesn't need us anymore and you make
some money
i make some money now on your only fans
yes you get a little risque or is it
just fema
uh it's risk more risque than my
instagram but i'm not nude or anything
you're not yeah no well it's only been
three months so it's only been a month
oh it's only been a month oh yeah it's
only been a month
it's just a month just a month what
would i for real do you think you make
zero dollars
are you a small asian girl big asian
just have your feet dude
chin goes do you think i do only fans
like play the guitar on them like you
have your dicks out
yeah if you get a harmonica with your
dick out some big things
everyone thinks they can do what cat
does
my girl's like should i do an only thing
like well no
no no please don't 54 year old white guy
a regular guy
he's 5 11 maybe 170. that's a dick on
him
i do have a dick on me huh and then
after
hey but here's the thing i was just
going to say i was walking that's
but your only fans i bet would come out
the gate hot and then after like
it's just a dick pic every week man yeah
it's just this old unless i was doing
[ __ ] like
running naked boxing you know spinning
boxing
naked you know what i mean you and i in
masks
yeah a
i get this i get i get a video from him
and it just goes hey bro
am i back now
[Laughter]
now because listen i'm glad we got what
is it what are we now ectomorph they
call us
yeah okay yeah more so you than me all
right i'm a mess oh more
all right uh these guys they on this
like 90 day the other way diet going on
yeah
and he's losing like 20 pounds and he's
down i can see the difference right now
well but i'm coming up to 200 what yeah
but why
yeah why do you need too high well
because i've never hit the two club
you don't want to get part of two cards
oh is that easy i can respect that not
as easy
to do something you know what yeah
that's why you do something let's do
something
he's only been you know when you've only
been boxing you're thin
yeah but your your mid section here
which is what i would work if we
actually got into it
yeah it doesn't matter you're lucky
there's not leg kicks involved oh
if i use my feet
don't make that spread it'll back just
don't let me use my feet
now the straight boxing oh no you beat
the oh he beat them you beat the grain
yeah you can buy oh well all that well
no i've seen it you showed me that video
no i can't box not
but it's true that there's nothing i'm
doing you're a little too loose with the
term
you're like in five months like with
jamar neighbors you guys
but you can fight too and jamar goes
well not like him
that's a very difficult loose with it
brennan once said to me i was with
i was working out with tarek and i tried
to spar with him and i
didn't do anything i got beat up and i
and i was frustrated and brennan said
ryan you can straight up box and you
were complimenting me yeah and that was
very nice but i can't
now now having said that yeah
i will take it in nigeria there's a
problem okay
i get a text from him
man let him explain he's so stupid let
me explain he's got a point you've been
hanging around too many white guys
it's what i what i do a lot of times in
like the third round when i'm getting
peppered up as i go
it's time to take them to nigeria now
what does that mean
i have an educated nigerian jab i study
uh
ass
[Laughter]
well anyway you're quietly impressed
with my jab and um
got some decent handling i got nothing i
got nothing
but i do like working out with you and
you do what have you uh
been doing brian the biggest besides
big and hungry besides talking to each
other every day what have you by the way
and that's the other thing just so
everybody knows
you know people say you know you and
brennan talk you know
what happened we talk every day
we would talk three times a day yeah
understand this
we talk every day and i don't think
we've taken a day off
never and we always it's always and
we're a couple gossip queens oh yeah
whatever well i'll get a text i'm like
i'll miss this call and go
got gossip call me bing what's up man
it's just a regular comment what do you
got for me
immediately our favorite thing is to go
bad
yeah if it's a good friend but go even
worse
harder but i don't know why people would
assume that you and i
we hate each other it's the craziest
thing well they just didn't know
what was going on but i want to thank
you guys for holding the fourth down
appreciate it
thank you doing a great job thank you
it's it's a it's it's a true [ __ ]
honor like
like i tell everybody like you're a big
reason why i [ __ ] moved out to
l.a i remember that day you gave me a
guest spot back in phoenix and you were
like yo
get out of here yeah you don't need to
be you were so good
i saw you know i i think i'm never wrong
about talent
never yeah i i saw it in him saw it in
you but you already had
you didn't need me and and i saw it in
him yeah you know the people that i
think are worth it are
i you know i just know and it's very
rare and it's more than talent it's
something different
but you're quite the renaissance man you
you got skateboarding
you got drunk you
kid you're doing like a like a count and
crows beat
[ __ ] absolutely love you jay-z over
there
that's great yeah yeah man
yeah man been holding it down what's
happening they've been holding it down
yeah yeah yeah listen i've been with sam
tripoli i'm doing that conspiracy social
club it's so fun
which is everything's a conspiracy well
he thought of it but you like debunk it
i do well shop called me up and said i
got it
i got this idea yeah you're going to
because
tripoli is going to hit you with
conspiracy theories and you're going to
debunk
the problem is it's it's when you're
arguing
hey we i love sam he's the only i want
people know
he's the only guy my idea for the show
you know a lot of comics like i just
can't right now with you guys can't
right now
sam's like i'll do it yeah yeah i'm like
your hell yeah
he's the best and then i'm i mean yeah
and so but but
the problem with sam is that if you go
but sam i can google that's not true
because google's [ __ ]
where do i go you use like duck.go
duckduckgo
what's that but every it's like a
conspiracy where they can't track your
[ __ ]
i guess but everything to sam's a
conspiracy like if you show up in m m's
like
you eat blue m m's yeah he's like you
don't know about those you're like
no he's like bush man
actually
what it comes down to is this i believe
most of the [ __ ] that goes on
is due to incompetence ambition
stupidity miscalculation okay right
and i don't think that anybody i don't
think anybody has enough power to
control all the strengths because there
are just too many competing interests
even within an
administration yeah but conspiracy
theorists believe
that people are way more organized than
than i do
correct i believe that people are number
one the people at the top are evil
yep they're all evil and and they're
really well organized
and they are interested mainly in
evil outcomes or at least control and
all of them and they all talk
that's what they think they they all
communicate and i think it's like
society like a secret system yeah but
but to your point i i think the prompt
like conspiracy
theorists like they put they almost give
too much credit to the government stuff
because
they make mistakes man a lot they make a
ton of money look at cuomo
look at the miscalculations what you
were saying you killed a lot of people
but it's like
yes i know i i don't think that was a
political you know that's not his agenda
no no because he didn't get recalled now
no he's [ __ ] he's super
dude you know gavin newsom who is who
kept us shut down there's a recall going
on i know he's
he's popular they don't want them no
there wasn't some big
plan to do all this they just at the
time they thought in their head that was
the right move and everyone's like oh
it's a conspiracy yeah
there's something behind everything yeah
like especially i think it's funner than
the truth
like did you watch a lot more on netflix
we talked about this little cat the
the ceso hotel one yeah so have you seen
the video of that weird girl in the
hotel i thought she was obviously
mentally disturbed
she climbed down clearly and she died
but how much fun like obviously the
the ceso hotel has a history people died
there guy who was he had that garbage i
know who lost his
poor there was a musician who he's like
a dark music i think marilyn manson
times ten
yeah yeah he's really not talented he's
really dark uh like
me dark no i mean like dark like inside
he's mexican but he like
but he talks about death and killing
like he seemed like a he's a guy who's
like an artist yeah he's not a and so
he was at the hotel a year prior a year
prior
and all the conspiracy theorists like he
stayed there he was there the same time
so they bombard his page
everything he does really like you
[ __ ] you killed her and all this
stuff he's like holy [ __ ]
he's like dude i have passports i have
uh studio documentaries say i was
here when she was killed i was there a
year ago oh so they blamed it on that
ruined his career
he doesn't do music because he sounds
better he has cyber bullying the truth
the conspiracy theory but even the cops
are like man i know like all these
conspiracies like but you're not
cops like there's information that we
can't leak you that we have right that
we know
a web sleuth yes a web slew
and they talked to this youtuber whose
balls deep in the cesa hotel
and he's like you know from my
calculations like yeah well you're not a
detective dude and the cops said that
cop said
there are things we don't release for
the family's sake yeah we don't want to
tell you
like she had horrible mental issues and
her sister told the district
a lot of meds yeah but for bipolar yeah
her sister goes she's had these
uh issues before these episodes where
she goes crazy thinks somebody's trying
to kill her and they're like oh that's
what was going on there because she
didn't have her medication
she's doing the [ __ ] in the in the in
the elevator and then she
thinks someone's trying to kill her try
to escape into the to the water [ __ ]
thing
and then goes inside there and yeah why
don't people listen to her family then
the problem is not funny
exactly that's not interesting but the
problem with with believing
in conspiracies like that or in the
in the fun thing is that you're missing
the actual threat yeah you know
the real threat we're facing i think in
this country is this polarization
between
magdaville and wokeville and and and
you know the media makes a lot of money
getting that keeping those divisions
keeping those two groups those two fills
fighting and they're actually but
they're both extreme but i think the
majority of people are in the middle
yes they're in the middle right so the
left on the right make the headlines and
left and right are on social media and
you can purify
the chamber too 99 of people are in the
middle yeah you know what i'm saying
like we're watching i might be i might
be a democrat i might be a republican
but i'm not them or i'm not there how
about this
i'm a republican i'm a democrat i'm a
centrist depending on the issue give me
the issue
yep what the [ __ ] i'm not just choosing
a team yeah you can't do that it can't
be complicated
let me let me be responsive to the
evidence you know that's what i think is
the big worry
i really do but i think that the media
summer elements media are ideologically
aligned to the far left because of the
way they've been educated and you have
the reaction on the other side
yes and if you start playing identity
politics i don't want to break people
into groups
i don't like this talk i don't think it
makes any sense i don't think it serves
any it doesn't move us in the right push
people into groups like in prison yards
yes
you you got to join the white aryans or
the black brotherhood or the [ __ ]
you have to survive if you're you want
to make the united states a [ __ ]
are we are is the united states a
[ __ ] painting is this
if you want to study if you're not
obsessed with color go to art school i
don't want to talk about color
i want to talk about potential and
merits and and who's the best person for
the job yes excuse me
i gotta run for prep oh
[Applause]
how about governor i feel like you could
beat newsome
yeah i don't know you know what you know
what's so funny hey
hey you next to newsom i know well you
look like a weathered worm
waiter
and not 20 minutes go by i'm not called
a weathered world
a [ __ ] weathered world next to the
newsome pickles
in the heat he's always saying next to
newsome he's always saying next no
no makes me look like a turd with ice
he's such a good looking dude but bad
ryan weathered worm calendar dude every
time he comes with a nickname i sell
shirts
you can have those my podcast was
burn i call it big and hungry i saw that
dude
so i get this from brennan like i'm
excited steve's [ __ ] hilarious and
it's great
yeah and it drops every monday it's all
good but
uh monday on youtube and apple oh yeah
all over you're playing with an asian
guy replace your two blocks
like this yeah whatever
he always like he always like he goes
hey first of all your [ __ ] backdrop
what is this and second of all there's
nothing big and hungry about a skinny
asian guy and a skinny white guy what
the [ __ ] are you doing i'm like
my i went like i was my girlfriend was
there and i went like this i go
she goes what's mine i go nothing no i
was in a sour mood because you were kind
of right
yeah yeah i went brian are you big
or hungry he goes no i it's steve
big or hungarians no i go why is it
called biggest hunger
i'm thin and moderate moderate
old white guy in asia wait so why why
[ __ ] that made me cry
yeah does it sound cool you
it's just not your wheelhouse it's not
in your wheelhouse you have so many
skills
when it comes to marketing it's like not
good but no bad at self-promotion
i know i gotta call you yeah but but
back to salmon conspiracies like
where it gets dicey is some conspiracies
i get
and i'm in on yeah like i'll talk to sam
and uh
and eddie like via group tax and some of
them they'll tell you like hey i can i
can get with that
like jfk 100 conspiracy 110
mafia induced and then uh september 11th
kind of edging on the conspiracy a
little bit there read
lawrence wright's book uh the looming
tower though he's
he does separate today oh i mean there's
a there's a paper trail
there's a cia trail there's a defensive
department defense trail there's an army
there's a trail to this
there was a there was a history of these
suicide bombs bombers
by a group called al-qaeda al-qaeda
which means the base in arabic
where's my camera you know what i mean
so it it it
you gotta you gotta read those books and
you'll go again it's like
the cia didn't bomb the united states
but this is where i'm at with conspiracy
it's like if i hear that's like all
right i'll read that
yeah and it can change my mind like i'm
not like sam and eddie where i'm like no
[ __ ]
that guy's in on it that arthur's in him
like nah man all right i'll read that
but it is fun to believe yeah especially
with tower seven
i mean yeah somebody gets dicey yeah
yeah yeah again so osama
but i've interviewed i've interviewed a
lot of full-time conspiracy theorists
like the guy who believes in flat earth
how now he's he's in his
he's my age and that's so sad does he
have kids
and then there was a guy who's a
chemtrail guy and what's very
interesting is that
if you're going to talk about chemtrails
or if you're going to talk about
flat earth yeah you might want to have a
background
in some kind of a scientific discipline
even engineering would be cool
whatever i'll take whatever you got
chemical engineering give me anything
whatever
geology how about astrophysics i'll take
it whatever i'll take if you took a
couple classes astrology
anything sure um and what i get is i go
now
what's your educational background and
immediately go well if you're going to
ask me if i have a paper from some
[ __ ]
institution yeah okay so there we are so
you've done your own
you are a web salute yeah but then they
all say this they all start with this
they all say
they all say i didn't i was i didn't
start as a conspiracy theorist i didn't
start
believing in this but i started looking
into it and then that means
you were educated by them and affirm
your bias yeah and it's fun
and it's fine but you get in the car
you're on your heels though you're on
your heels once they go
i didn't get a [ __ ] degree from you
talking about the institutions like
you mean college dude no no and then
you're just like all right well what
happens
also though is if you have a guy who's a
full-time flat earther
yeah they have a lot of information yeah
they they're going to hit you with a
thousand things i
don't work on flat earth because don't
believe it yeah
yeah well because science and other
things and so
you're not a scientist so you're not
going to be able to kind of you're not
going to be able to mount some
defense when they say have you ever seen
a satellite with your own eyes have you
ever seen you know and you're like
i don't know but that's what about
flight patterns but that's what they do
like that's their thing so they're ready
to whatever you have they
they have it in the chat well i said
when so you're not if you're not ready
for the argument man
it looks like they know what they're
talking about but when you when i said
when you
when you chart a flight from here to
australia
you have to take into account the
curvature of the earth and he said yeah
but
a lot of pilots are speaking up about
this now because they're just being uh
huh so they're being sent on routes that
they're all in they'll be that long i
see so they're all in on and also that
all that fuel haven't bee have you ever
seen the i'm you should show this to sam
on your show there's a video of this
he's a big flat earther and he's like uh
he set a date he's like i'm gonna prove
it
i'm gonna get up before sunrise and he
has this tool that shows like
the earth he said it's gonna show it
just goes up and down and not like
and he's like with the curve yeah yeah
and it curves and you just hear him go
ah
[ __ ]
and the camera shuts off
[Laughter]
you can also set up lasers you can shoot
a laser through a hole if you if
everything was flat you could you know
yeah
and you know this guy this flat earther
nice guy i don't want to i don't want to
out
these guys but but he but he uh it
apparently that the laser was oh
things get tweaked see i like i like
this uh use on world star it says flat
earth who gets a wake-up call
that's a great handle
but i shouldn't have to talk about it
it's fun though right yeah
it was fun probably the first four
episodes well i love sam
sam and i just [ __ ] yeah because
he's not always sam
sam tripoli is a great comic legend he's
[ __ ] you know it's like steve too
like i did a so we did a live podcast in
nashville foreign and and steve is on
stage now steve's been doing stand-up
for 25 years and when you see that
[ __ ]
improvise with an audience you know i
was watching him and i was like
this is you'll love this guy i go i look
at him and i look at him and i'm like
this [ __ ] is so good
he's been doing this for 25 years so
he's got a bag of tricks
that is well it's bigger than santa's
bag he can just pull out and just come
up with whatever
then a guy named theo vaughn
came on in the last 15 minutes you guys
aren't ready for that smoke
smoke i mean that dude will come on and
just start saying crazy
[ __ ] and if he's on you're just like oh
i don't i don't have the same
wavelength that he's oh my god we do
king of sink sometimes and
like you know a guest would do a
submission and he's just firing away i'm
like i just
my brain doesn't work like my god like
his crazy but it all makes sense yeah
and the references are so
yeah and but interesting and like out of
left field you're like oh
he said to me i was talking like this
and i said yeah and he goes you sound
like a guy
in a who's coming out from behind a
curtain in a castle right now
he's just [ __ ] but it makes sense oh
god damn he's [ __ ] hilarious he's
great he
he uh moved to nashville about a house
we're looking at him he's looking at
yeah he's looking at property you know
um
because you were thinking about buying
them well you know there's nashville and
there's austin
i was in texas oh okay in a blizzard and
no power you know now a couple things
about taxes if you
texas is great now now come talk to me
and you know this
in june july and august and september
because if you think you know hot daddy
i'm i'm well you're from arizona
arizona yeah he's from america here's
the difference dry
texas gets all kinds of humidity houston
i can't [ __ ] with houston in the summer
you're walking through
probably like you lie you're like you
can't really even go out like
it's different than vegas it's like it
you ruined your clothes
you feel bad for your shoes yeah the
ground's so hot august in san antonio
i the woman sees me walking out of the
hotel and
she goes where are you going i go i'm
walking to starbucks and she said
starbucks is almost half a mile away i
said yeah she goes you're not walking to
starbucks
and i go i am she goes oh it's too hot
hun
and i go i am i've lived in saudi arabia
i took about 10 steps
you burn my back [ __ ] up
by the center of the sun what the [ __ ]
is going on
but and then i got hit by locusts yeah
oh yeah yeah
hey but the thing is like last summer in
woodland hills
we reached one like 116 yeah 115
and it's like hot dude yeah you came
like even the pool is not comfortable oh
yeah like
walking to the pool you your third
degree burns your sandals
it's just like i'm just staying yeah
it's too hot to swim yeah i can deal
with hot i can't deal with humidity
though
that's like florida yeah dry santa dry
heat all day for me dry heat i could
take dry heat
yeah that humidity i was down in miami
and from my hotel room i watched a shark
swim you're lying you know what you're
one of them know what and i'm fine with
it no no you know what that was all is
you're going to think i'm lying and i
would be lying and i'm alive however
the mountain light are you and rogan oh
that was the greatest yeah
i see mountain lions mountain lions all
the time and i go like this i stop and i
go
no you don't everyone goes and he goes
he i don't know i do i do no i have i
swear to god i go i know i know you
swear to god
they're around there though they're
around yeah
[Laughter]
you don't know what they look like
because yeah so you saw a shark do you
mind
yeah no i'm in my i'm in my balcony and
i looked down and
we saw i'm still a manatee first a
manatee
and even that's in that stuff
and i was looking down and then and then
uh
and then i said it's swimming yeah
shadow and it was coming and i was like
get out of the water
from your balcony did he look up no
because i was
i was on floor 36
i i saw a shadow coming up this guy i'll
have to prove [ __ ] to you guys
and then the shadow was like this and i
was like out
and then the shadow didn't change
direction
all right guys i'll see you later
what's up did you did you see uh
schultzy at all in miami i don't know
we texted but you know he's he's like
down there
he's down there down there doing a
little boxing boxing
all right is it not good just better
than me listen i love that kid
i love that kid not a boxer don't just
tell them not to get
too excited don't get in there don't get
in the don't get in the nose
don't get in the ring with me oh don't
get in the ring is this a challenge it's
not bad
no it's not bad this is great i wish
he'd use his reach more but that's okay
oh
i like the dip yeah it's all good oh
yeah
yeah but just you know what i mean
season yeah ooh
not bad he said oh it's flowing out of
shape right
that's pretty good you can hit mitts oh
everybody until they get hit is what
you're saying well it
you all know you know that you can look
real good on kids
for him just getting shot better than
lamar odom
yeah way better than lamar you know
lamar odom's fighting
no he's not yeah he needs money he's
fighting really
wait wait wait
and you quit cheating on your diet can i
see some video on him though i mean he
is oh you got to see the video you would
mop
the floor with him brian oh no and we
mean that he's fighting aaron carter
there's something about there's
something about fighting
there's something about fighting that's
i don't know it's just different than
sports there
right brennan i don't know what it is
that's the same train that trains kevin
hart
you know what he box like those rope
those red and blue robots
yeah i guess he's maybe is he just
keeping that glued and trying to
he he's never boxed before no he's never
forever first time he's never done
this i'm not gonna lie i like how he
brings his hands back to his face yeah
yeah cause he'll do that in real time
aaron carter i don't know i think he
needs money for chris listen anytime
there's a slurry boxing match nobody
who's doing well in life is doing
celebrity boxing yeah
he's probably doing fine he just wants
to be probably he's not doing dude he
died in a [ __ ] house in vegas he woke
up though
was it big titty kitty or something like
that it is it's the bunny right yeah
he's not about he has money but he
doesn't though
he's not doing this because he's sad no
one does celebrity boxing because of the
show
people go dude would you do celebrity
boxing no because things are going well
no you said you would box the rock you
did say that that's different
because the rock has [ __ ] going i have
[ __ ] going would you feel bad about
beating the [ __ ] out of him
uh i i no one would be he would never
he would never no one would be rooting
for me listen i probably wouldn't even
do that unless there's like some
guarantee like 30 40 million but yeah
i am things are good man if you see me
on cameo
if you see me doing celebrity boxing
dancing with the stars yeah what if jake
paul
what if jake paul challenged you to
boxing because he can box and he's like
uh i'm so much bigger than him and
they're also no they're not like are you
that much bigger than him oh yeah
are they about jake or logan because
logan's the biggest one
no i'm saying j oh so jake is smaller
yeah smaller
logan's bigger logan's probably maybe
200 yeah he's more than 180
yeah what is it that's right that's one
real life for jake no like they're not
gonna
yeah every bit of sticks dude he's a
bigger guy but like we did the food
truck together i'm way bigger than him
yeah and he's top ten so it's like
they're not gonna be like no let's go
for brendan no
that would be a big mistake it's a bad
idea you can't do that they know they
want to box and make money like that's
not the best
yeah you'd get hurt i'm outside of real
profession i'm also not famous enough
like
fight the you know the floyd mayweather
i think a lot of people would tune in to
fight watching you fight but it wouldn't
i i i know what you mean it'd be stupid
like you were in the ufc what are you
doing
nothing like no one's gonna be rooting
for me oh the guy who beat gabriel
gonzalo merkel crocodile but he's
fighting a youtuber go brendan like
nobody yeah
no good luck man like what no it doesn't
make sense
that doesn't make sense dude are you
still sparring yeah let me get back to
you
[Laughter]
no your chin is dead i'm just ready
do you notice now that malek's on this
show and he has a little bit of money
like he has a rolex out here first of
all
he's the rolly boy well he is that what
that's right what's your friend
i gotta buy something makes me angry
don't throw him home he's your friend he
calls me he was like yo are you
rapping now yeah no no
i was like what do you mean no because
if you want to go straight i'm like
don't say street like that if you want
to go street yeah i can show you what's
up
i'll get street
now don't get it wet in the shower yeah
okay so it's not
wait what no no you're dead it's a
it's a starter watch it's a starter
watch that's the same thing joe coy said
let's get started
we're in san francisco and you go is
that real yeah that's real and he goes
oh my dad has one can i see you you want
me to take it off because yeah take it
off let me just hold it
and he goes that's not real bubba so
this is the same thing are you saying if
you were
you're actually embarrassed she was
embarrassed yeah i never wore it again
oh really no i said i went oh this is no
this is so yours is real though
well listen i i have a it tells time
listen
i have a i have a girl who loves me
who's who's worth six figures and
she we took it to but how much does that
run
it's 30k that's 30k yeah you dropped 30k
well the real one's stirred well the
real
wait wait wait hold on now what you
think this is that's
that is a let brian hold it yeah let me
see what's going on with it let brian
catch right now yeah cool gold has a
density to it
his weight yeah
though it sounds like i feel like you're
pretending you can't get it off
i can't get it off
it might be fake who knows what else you
got to pray
if you can touch it it's real yeah like
i said it tells time
it tells time it looks and it looks like
it looks legit as [ __ ]
no that's right i don't own it it's real
to me you could rob my house and you get
t-shirts what did you live on a bike
the most expensive thing you'd get that
i own are the gucci boots you made me
buy that you never
never worn they're just a little too
tight on my feet you don't have gucci
boots
you got some
a gucci book shopping once yeah
we're in fact that was there in vegas he
goes you need you need expensive shoes i
can't take this anymore
because i was wearing those bad black
dress shoes that i bought in canada i
was wearing
i was wearing the kind if you sell
insurance and you are down on your luck
those are the shoes you wear because the
only ones you want yeah you look like
you sold chrysler's
i mean it was it was like i looked like
a 1950s pitch on a 300 chrysler yeah
you're like all right and you know it's
not
things have not worked out yeah and
that's what i was wearing and they were
the worst boots i've seen
you guys were laughing so hard when i
took them off you were laughing they
looked like clown shoes
you know when andy dufresne puts his
shoes back in the box on shawshank
redemption and takes the good ones yes
his shoes look like andy you know what
it is
when you when when you're just living
your life with those students when you
don't have money and nobody knows you
and you die
and they and some nice woman says we
gotta dress the corpse up a little bit
you put those shoes on yeah right and do
you remember that guy in gucci
i do he spent he put him on he goes whoa
it was god damn he started gots to have
these and started dancing
do you remember when we did that uh that
show
calendar in vegas and with jimmy walker
and we're getting ready
and he goes he's in a tux and he has
like a handler who's his wife and he's
been in comedy for 60 years
actually eddie murphy references him in
his special that's how he was a big deal
back in the day
he was the guy who was dying oh mike
yeah yeah
he's a tommy store regular yeah the good
times guy so
we're we're waiting to go on we're
waiting to go on
and they're like would you like to meet
jimmy or yeah i guess i don't know who
he is brian doesn't like yeah i guess
dude this is our opener they wouldn't
let us book our own openers like he's
the only opening of this club
okay and finally comes in he won't look
at me or brian he's just staring around
the room
and then me and brian get close we're
like what's up man glad you're doing the
show yeah
you know he said i know everybody i
never heard of you two
and then just walked away he said he
said when i found out then they told me
who it was i went
yikes
what does that mean man yikes is like
ooh we're gonna we're staying at
this we're staying at this hotel yeah
and then brian hits me just be nice be
nice because i was like i'm gonna
roast the [ __ ] out of this yeah and then
he went on stage open up and then you
know what he has like
had old references like he doesn't
update his act in a hot second
he's like making like saved by the bell
references not the reunion like the old
school yeah
he's talking about like uh survivor and
[ __ ] everyone's like what like our
crowd's like what the [ __ ] so wait he
hosted
yeah he hosted and then he goes make
sure you get your sign
eight by tens and dvds if you want them
in the back
and i want stage hey everybody make sure
you get your
dvds on the way out you know just like
you want to shake his hand and he goes
whoa don't touch me don't touch me
brother i'm like oh [ __ ] yeah
that's why i started clowning him yeah i
think he had something was going on
he's he's not a he's funny and off the
cuff jokes around
he might have been [ __ ] with us i'm
gonna give him the benefit of the doubt
oh i'm not no
no i know [ __ ] around there's no he
did not like us
which is fine i mean was it a good show
overall though yeah well i mean listen
uh hey not that one time we were in
phoenix that thursday night yeah
and we all [ __ ] we all ate [ __ ] we all
ate [ __ ] man you came back like that's
the
one of the worst crowds i've ever seen
yeah sometimes like i ate [ __ ]
yeah that's so yes sometimes no matter
what you're just gonna be
yeah and you know sometimes audiences
are like nashville for example
most of those people play an instrument
and when you have musicians
it's not that they don't love you but
they're watching you differently
your bag of tricks they're ahead of you
yeah like sometimes
you can wow people with comedy right you
can come out there and do [ __ ] and
they're just
they're just they don't see comedy it
might be only the second time they've
seen comedy so they're already like and
then
everybody's laughing they're like this
is fun it's contagious yeah
when you're a performer when you've been
on stage when you play the guitar or
whatever
and you understand rhythm they can see
that what they're doing is they're going
they're watching you they're watching
the stage presence and they they've been
around they've been on they've been up
there so they're looking at it very
differently they're just they're just
taking they're putting themselves in
your position
yeah the crowd was quiet huh daddy no no
no no no no actually
what he said right he shot him breaking
down like mommy kids
and they went in the back was like their
music you know they're listening
no no you no i didn't bother
[Applause]
the younger the comics that were opening
for me were
came out and said you know that some of
my stuff wasn't hidden and i go and i
had to say to them i go when i first
came to nashville
i had that experience yeah and i was
told by the club owner he said
this is they are watching you
differently yeah because i like that you
guys feel better about that
stuff yeah but i i mean i crushed yeah
yeah
i mean they had both it also sounds like
sounds like they were a little quiet
though
yeah yeah no they were good but what is
that that's oh it's supreme i like that
teddy hey you i'll never forget i was we
was boxing one time at his house
and he wore these big ass clown boots
and there's like what a thousand dollars
those black ones
yeah and i was like bro what are you
doing yeah he has like some what
for boxing no i'm talking about like
some dress shoes some boots someone sent
them to you
yeah i don't remember you remember that
i work and you said i was like bro
that's embarrassing and he was like
y'all got an ass on me though
you remember that yeah i do have an
[ __ ] like well that has nothing to do
with my shoes
no but i do have an ass on me and and
one of the things that you don't have
and it's all good is you don't have
much of a lower body right some would
say nothing
no no you can tell my legs are getting
you've been working your legs yeah i've
been working myself
still but your body is your upper leg
workout now he's still he puts out
muscle
in his chest and his back yeah yeah yeah
hey you know what you know who else
doesn't have legs camaro usman
i looked at his legs and i was like i
mean him he couldn't get bigger and
stronger and i looked at his legs his
thighs
i looked at his it's so interesting his
upper body's jack
jack and then you look at his legs and i
was like your legs are actually
they might be the smallest it might be
the smallest in the other so you're
saying like great superior athletes have
legs now
take it easy but listen he'll still
wreck it that is the one thing about
fighting it gives hope to all guys with
small legs yeah who's that tall guy
in that uh yeah who's damn there's a
skinny
who has a skinny slice i don't know no
that's just some random dude
that's not john that's not jon jones
that guy is skinny john jones got real
stupid i guess i'm so basic he's a
basketball player basketball players you
know they're not gonna
that's john's legs yeah see [ __ ]
identical he's got
zero captain is that a that might be
photoshopped
that's
is it going to be the same thing exactly
that's right thank you all due respect i
think so too
see his legs aren't yeah see they're not
big like francis or
dc's but yeah but you know what they are
big kind of up here
you know what they get the job done he's
the best we've ever seen he's also 250
apparently like
he's jacked like people don't realize
he's 250. yeah my friend's drama he's
like
he's my friend yeah my friend's a big
guy my friend said
i don't know what people are talking
about him being skinny dude i was
looking at his thighs i was looking at
his back he's [ __ ] huge he's huge
yeah he's real tall right he's six you
know every bit of six five
every inch could be six six but every
bit of six five every bit of six five
yeah did you have did you ever train
with him oh yes but you did oh yeah
yeah oh yeah oh jackson's number times
monster absolute monster
yeah will destroy the heavyweight
division he will destroy you you're
putting money on
against stipe 100 is that right he
smokes all of them
the only one that scares me for him
would be francis because he gets hit
he gets him francis hits you it's a game
over it's a game but if you just take
francis down if you don't get hit takes
him down it's easy work for him yeah
although stipe might be as good a boxer
or a better boxer right or no
uh he's he's more one-dimensional like
he doesn't really kick
you know he can kick but he really
doesn't jon so dynamic with his striking
elbows
you know you can south paul traditional
so now he's
bigger he's also a wrestler he is a
better wrestler oh yeah
damn john's a monster b you're on the
road
every single week would you say well uh
this week
this weekend i'll be at the virginia
beach funny bone everybody and then
i'm at jacksonville comedy zone ooh too
short and six
i know dude that's the problem
when i see jacksonville like i go i go
tampa
spokane i go i go tampa spokane
cleveland miami you have you been to
jacksonville
i've not done it yet you have i haven't
done the club no that comedy zone's new
yeah i know it's been around 37 years i
don't know that
they used to be a restaurant they
changed the coming zone right i guess
the only time i went to jackson was you
and me when you bombed in front of
tebow's
oh boy that was
and i got you know they prayed and then
brought brian up i'm like i feel like
really it's a bad order maybe you should
pray before the meal gets served not
after brian yeah oh [ __ ] who's that
black guy who is an amazing singer
oh uh like it's so envious of him yeah
he won american idol assumptions i know
he won uh the voice
yeah goddammit oh the
i i showed you you showed it yeah he's a
monster yeah i brought him out
yeah so you're in the road non-stop dog
i'm on the road now
omaha nebraska november 11 12 13. oh
yeah remember that yeah yeah yeah i'm at
school
there we go funny bone omaha march 11 12
13.
comedy zone you road dog now yeah road
yeah what happens sometimes look
sometimes in life
you get hit with a little chaos little
blip you got to pivot and adjust
keep moving keep writing by the way you
know what's you know what and all
[ __ ] aside
no matter what you're going through in
life what's [ __ ] beautiful about
stand-up or anything
is you can take all that energy that you
could put into anxiety or depression or
anger and just [ __ ] put it into
writing
wouldn't you act that's all i'm doing i
wrote a whole [ __ ] new hour basically
yeah
yeah for real that's what's up yeah for
real like i have i've literally
wrote probably an hour yeah of new [ __ ]
because it's just energy and also with
stand stand-up though no matter what
goes on with social media or you know
whatever ellie times writes
the audience and the public are going to
decide if you have a career or not
that's right if they come to your shows
you have a career that's right and and
just don't get lazy just keep writing
that's the [ __ ] hardest thing it's so
easy to get
relaxed you know i don't know you stay
active
did did you mess up why i work out every
day did you work out everything
that's why my body looks like this it's
coming back i mean a lot of it's genetic
most small a weathered well you don't
you don't eat crazy at all right
no no no no i need to know your diet
then i'm a heater
no you don't you hey you're not brian
you're also on his diet
you don't want brian's diet he doesn't
eat mcdonald's though okay
y'all went to mcdonald's in west palm
beach i don't eat no [ __ ] mcdonald's
you went to mcdonald's
that's a different time he's a
late-night secret eater not anymore no
what are you wearing right now i don't
know my i find it very endearing that
the one thing that you're a little
you you're you like to say you're 250.
no i don't i
didn't he did not say it i'm proud of
you okay
no it's not comfortable
he was fighting he was flirting with
trying to get down to 202.
it was like it was like a samoan man
trying to be trying to get into
a pair of high heels just who has a
woman trapped inside of him yeah it was
like
john tony straight it was [ __ ] tough
he got down like
4 35 and he was like
that was the nightmare are you trying to
get to 205 that's not i was gonna
yeah i was thinking about it it ain't
not anymore yeah no no at that time yeah
i don't think it's i don't think it's
possible for you you could guys do it
but it's just it would be
but you would look weird at two o'clock
i would like to be i don't know would be
skinny
yeah you're you're a true heavyweight
yeah it's a bummer
did you feel like a good weight for you
is two three two forty two four is that
right not 250
no 240 so 272 but i thought you were you
were you were biking and
i am you were you you just eat a jello
loose
what what what are you what's your go-to
pizza
i love pizza yeah pizza and thai yeah
well you know i can't say
who should go to secrets
you said it like i'm dealing because
it's delicate right now
some people like some people like steve
byrne steve
likes the feeling what he likes to do is
eat all the apple pies
from mcdonald's and all the hamburgers
and then and then go over to arby's and
go
and he's got a whole list and then he
likes to like a jungle snake
after a snake eats a [ __ ] like uh
something he can't eat it just has to
stretch
he likes the feeling of being too full
and watching tv
and just not being able to move that me
i don't if he's comfortable with it
if that's his thing people like that to
be built like somebody's aunt like
that's the
but he's not he's not a big dude no he's
got my skinny fat mentality
he's skinny fat yeah but he's got a very
good frame it's just
he gets away with it because he puts
some people put weight on evenly other
people put on weight on like
just their tummy or their tummy [ __ ]
yeah mine's like is that where your
issues are yeah are you lifting weights
if i had your frame i'd be [ __ ] too
big
uh skinny there yeah yeah oh yeah yeah
just kidding
yeah he said he's that guy eats arby's
he's the
i think steve is the i'm going to say it
i think in my 54 years i think he's the
nicest
he's the nicest human being i've ever
met in my life he's truly the the
he's such a good person he's always been
nice to me
there's no one who doesn't love him
who's the non-keto guy in the terrible
shirt
i don't know who that guy is the
terrible shirt
the mini hana shirt who's the non keto
yeah who's non-keto keith over there
do you know who that is i don't know now
you don't but you don't
lift you can do it i have it in a minute
because there's the gyms are open
right i miss it i miss well i give you
kettlebells and the jump rope and stuff
kettlebell yeah in the jump rope but i
mean i hate when people say the gyms
aren't open
yeah i know that yeah the gyms brian
this stuff you can do though there's
mountains
yeah how about you left the 260 pounds
yeah you'll be quiet you're on the same
[ __ ] yeah
i listen to you
fan oh you're the best yeah here's the
thing you're the best
hey come on you're built like jerome
battis and it's [ __ ]
fun bring up the bus bring up the bus
you would have been you can you could
you could have been a hell of a running
back you would have been you had to run
right through that was a great
cheerleader they would have had
you built like jerome bettis there he is
yeah that guy's a running back it's not
there's nothing to be mad about look at
him big boy
they call him the bus and he's a running
back he left one of the great
notre dame hall of fame let me see a
highlight
that's you that's you that's you a
highlight 100 that's you by the way
that's a great question
first of all you're the best you're the
best
his legs are way bigger than mine well
he's in shape you got some big legs
you were i was watching you carrying
like it was a lunch box oh yeah we
worked out with kevin bay yeah yeah
phoenix cause uh he doubted me that i
could carry a hundred pound dumbbells
you didn't no biggest fan no you're very
strong now you're not shop
now now i i didn't say i was they're
strong
we know this there's there he's got a
weird thing going on he's got that
he's got that bear strength for real but
you're very strong thank you you're very
strong
you're probably more explosive than
brendan so if you really trained i think
you might get him on squats
yeah he's he's built for scratch yeah
yeah
not deadlift i don't know if you're
getting in my 40. i don't know if you're
getting them on deadlift and i don't
think you're getting it what do you get
dead lift
what about well his name a number his
brother oh my gosh
you destroy that can i i'd do that right
you know
4 15. educate him he'll do it he'll do
it you wake him up from a nap
wake him up from a nap
well well i watched him well i watched
him i watched him
i watched him take 5 50. and i watched
him do 10
sets i watched him do 10 reps and then
he did 10 sets of 10 reps
now hold on hold on he did he did 5 50.
100 times opponent times a hundred times
okay now now i said to his brother i
said now jay's no wheeling either jj
does jay goes if you put a 500 pound on
the floor right now i'll lift it right
now
you're eating lunch and he goes he get
that's when he gets he gets all kinds of
feedback
yeah i'll lift 500 pounds he pointed the
ground to an imaginary
okay straight bar but he said that
brennan when brendan was lifting when he
was dead lifting when he was really when
he's playing football
the gym owner came over and goes you
guys can't do this
and they say well i go you're brandon
you're bending my bars
he was bending me
so so what's your max what's your math
probably in the sevens
are you serious so wait why is why is
squat weird for you then
just i'm talking that oh the taller you
are the hardest squad is the biggest i
don't think you worked on it either
right squad yeah yeah
i see you for sure okay an nfl first i
mean squat was super important yeah
yeah but but what do you squat yeah well
yeah what'd you get some legs who's
squad well when i
when i when i do like i set up any
nights i'm getting some weight
i i am squat simply weak well
jocko willik i listened to him i just
had to he'll get you motivated well but
jacqueline
is almost my age i don't know he's 50
maybe i don't know what he is yeah and
and uh different though yeah a lot
different than me
but jocko could talk me into killing
somebody yeah he's awesome he's awesome
i never met him but i love him
but he was having a very intense
conversation about
whether or not with with his buddy echo
whether or not uh
they go that you go deep though you go
deep he goes now i go
to the chair and go see and i squat and
i'm like dude well we in high school
right now
what's going on and you got to go deep
did you did you when you were out in
texas did you see tim kennedy at all
another guy who could talk me into
killing somebody yes so so so when i was
there
his buddy i think it's randy who is
in a lot of the pictures with him if you
see two guys tim
and a guy on it who they have their
shirts off they're both shut up they're
really wide and thick
that would be his buddy i think it's oh
god is it
no they're just popping up with couture
no it's not randy it's uh
shane maybe maybe great got him a great
guy so he
shows up in a helicopter with alex jones
who i alex jones driving the helicopter
uh alex jones was up was in the
helicopter and they landed
in the street outside the studio kind of
illegally got out
alex jones had a long talk with him
interesting very nice
at the airport uh no at the at the
studio
what'd you guys talk about um there he
is there that guy right there
that guy right there yeah now his he
used to be a country
music guy and now he i think he's he
owns a lot of property he's like a big
property owner in austin
and he's real close to tim and i got a
text apocalypto here
i got a text from tim as i got on the
plane saying if you ever come to my
state again
and you don't call me i'm going to beat
your funny
witty head in i'm like i was in dallas
and he
loved him yeah thumbs down and i said
but if i
do i will throughs are [ __ ] huge yeah
tim kennedy
you know who tim is no special forces oh
he's dead fighter he's a strike first
champion
and i heard not from tim but through the
through the grapevine that
jocko and tim rolled they did a little
jiu jitsu together
i see him right there jim all respected
he's pretty tall
no no no he's no tim is about five
maybe five nine not an ounce of fat he's
thinking the nicest smartest guy you
know
but it's interesting because people like
jack was a gorilla on the mat and kill
her but
but you know from what i understood too
and this is he went toe to toe with
jacare yeah
so tim is going to beat you we got to be
cool tim's going to beat you in
jiu-jitsu
yeah no matter who's still training
jiu-jitsu i i i live jiu jitsu dude yeah
no but i do do a little jiu jitsu look
at tim's legs
[ __ ] calves no tim he's made for
killing people tim is as thick
a human being as it gets do you guys
like your freedom you like like be like
have an opinion your freedom
yeah thank him yeah you thank him you're
welcome
tim fights he's so he's so he was
special he was arguably i'd say arguably
top three 185 in the world for the
longest time i mean
beat basically beat you all romero or
certainly to a draw and then it went
i mean he's fought everybody was struck
was a strikeforce champion i mean a
monster a monster always always the guy
you didn't want to fight
and oh by the way oh by the way also
while being a ufc contender was also a
special ops guy like an active
specialist still a green beret retired
retired from the ufc and still
he would just disappear like me and
brennan oh like i could text him right
now like i text him the other day
uh talking about something with politics
and he answered the question i was like
all right dude gotta go
and it's like he doesn't show me where
he's at but just shows me a picture in
his uniform
with this like special badge i can tell
he's like
in a helicopter yeah it's like a hit
over a desert
like over a jungle i think i called him
i called him the other day and he goes
he answered the phone like this he goes
america
america how great is that guy he's
interested in all
this in austin also a great guy but also
like a silly goose oh yeah like
super funny like we love brent and i
when we did a podcast with him
like a couple of school kids we got in
the car and and we went and brennan goes
is he the greatest guy in the world is
that my imagination because he's
he's he's the best he's the best he's
just a great guy
yep i hope to meet this dude yeah if we
get off if we go to austin you will dude
that was before i was
either mark
but i'm going back to that because
that's a [ __ ] good-looking guy right
it's a great-looking dude
for hims.com promo code shop so if you
want to look like brian there
poor hands beforehand
dude what is he doing right there on top
of the table he's about to attack brian
i think yeah oh shh yeah and i'm all for
it hey look at that
look at that is exciting yes well that
was the day brennan cried
yep yeah but i have a theory with that
because we did dmt
i think that's exactly that's what he
did like brandon started bawling
did you do it too i sure did yeah it's
fantastic
i could not stop we were taken through a
ceremony we were taken to a ceremony
with a shaman
by the name of aubrey martin i saw him
by the way you did
how is he i was in san marcos he's doing
great i miss him he's doing great we're
in san marcos that's
what's he doing just hanging out being
fabulous with a is he wearing like
he's married beads he's married now
married he's married oh the guy that
came in the green room
yeah yeah that's my guy yeah aubrey went
through aubry and just
a gamut of trying to figure out
relationships from ligaments you'll love
this
so love aubrey right there's his wife
they dated before
broke up he did his thing uh tried being
uh polygamist
you know do all that thing and then got
married and she's a smoke
show spectacular well so that's his wife
and he's winning and so
you love this he comes to the green room
and he's with justin wren and justin
wren had just found out
one of his friends uh close friends
kid committed suicide so justin comes in
just got done balling her face is all
red the
the vibes in the green room with death
and we're talking about ct we're talking
about a friend who i'll tell you about
after
we're talking about horrible stuff and
like all right shop you're on in ten i'm
like
hey turn around go don't ever come to a
show again
don't ever come to the show with this
energy again oh my [ __ ] god
that's like when aubrey was laughing so
hard i'm like you can't no you can't i
gotta go make them laugh yeah it was
like right before the show
i had to do i had to do jennifer garner
brought me on stage
because i was doing i was emceeing i was
auctioning off
uh certain paraphernalia to raise money
for two children that have a very rare
genetic disease two little girls that
are gonna die
yes and dad gets up he can barely hold
together
mom gets up she can't hold it together
and then jennifer garner goes and now
brian
no it's like this it's like right here
no you don't grab it
yeah boom and it's that yeah
hey bro you can't get it you can't get
in the middle fingers
crossed yeah it's called the apple pie
it's called the apple pie
the character is called two creepy white
guys so go ahead
no it's called two white guys trying to
be black oh hell yeah
dude wait no why you thinking that's
gross it's like this guy's why your
fingers
what are you doing this guy is doing
this
why are you making that note i don't
know i've never been
i've never been sandwiched twix two
black guys
all right what do you guys got for us
today
you take this [ __ ] off guys
crank the heat up yeah i think no i
turned it i turned it
down i can't i can't remember she's
wearing the one love shirt
yeah you know i got you brian i love you
i love jen
i love cat i miss you guys miss you good
to see you
how's it going how are you huh
you didn't say stevie i hate it for a
while but uh you can say it now
i love it i love it he's good steve he's
trying to hazel house
he likes his girl he likes the cat he's
in the cat he's in the cab
i think he caught himself the best so
uh-huh got himself a six-figure queen
[ __ ] yeah
that's not what it is no different than
malik and his girl like welcome to the
call yourself
by the way i'm your girl is fantastic by
the way you tried to highlight her a
couple of times i was kind of
well we had there's a whole weird thing
i don't give a [ __ ] but
he said i'll give a [ __ ] i don't know
[ __ ] it's worth it
there's just a pause
and then we're over it over it yes
i've turned my charisma down a little
bit
okay so we've talked about aisha curry
in the past she
is uh stephen curry's wife uh
and in the past she's gotten a lot of
hate for tweets that she's tweeted out
back in 2015
basically saying that uh she would
rather wear more clothes
and be dressed properly and that girls
who show more skin
are considered trashy and she wants to
be classy uh
since she has recently been losing
weight she's been more
provocative with the things that she
posts on instagram social media like
bikinis
or and recently she did where she's nude
yeah
so she posted this photo recently she
did a nude photo shoot where you don't
really see anything but she's naked and
a bunch of people are
brilliant
but yeah a lot of people are just giving
her backlash on stuff like this saying
that she's a hypocrite that's how it
goes when you're the big chunky girl you
hate on the hot skinny girls and you get
hot and skinny
like i get it and they start posting
pics yeah she's going at all so what did
she what were her tweets
go up to her tweets uh she is everyone's
into barely wearing clothes these days
huh
not my style i keep the good stuff
covered up for the one who matters
just looking at the latest fast trends
i'll take classy over trendy any day of
the week
hashtag saturday night in sight
keep going keep going i mean this is
some
female [ __ ] that i just don't get it
it's yeah it's hyper female
she doesn't have a super male this is
because and all i'm doing is sitting
here reading style weekly you guys
definitely entertain me that's for sure
she was regardless if you like my style
clothes or not which i don't care please
do not tear women down to grade them
not cool peeps you while she was just
doing that boom
got skinny oh [ __ ] 35 pounds yeah yeah
and she you also forgot that she uh was
mad about like
uh her getting attention and stuff like
that no her not getting it
she was like i can't believe steph curry
gets attention and that was the time i
was in her dms
yes she was saying dudes don't look at
you know i was looking i i'm
i'll make a confession this is a weird
confession i've never told you the story
but i there was a girl i used to date
and then she
we broke up and then she she gained a
bunch of weight after the breakup
it's sort of like you know during it
it just things get people just get
sloppy got comfortable
and she just she just had she was
already thin but like when you're thin
and
when you put on 20 pounds that's a lot
like that can be what's everything right
it's heavy yeah
right yeah she's built like toe jamming
she went from toe jam say that stuff i'm
not saying
[Music]
and after go to images one is skinny one
is thick
tells your girl on the right come up
with the craziest questions
nobody but like japanese
ever heard of him no there's there's
some uh 80s babies out there like hell
yeah toe jam and earl
damn that's good all right carry on uh
so so
i kind of like we broke up and then she
said something like uh
like she said she was dating someone
that's cool she goes yeah you don't care
about that part of my life at all
anymore huh
and i was like all right well she kind
of still liked me and i was like no i
mean you're doing your thing it is what
it is
and then i saw her about
about two months maybe three months
later and she
lost it all and had and was working out
daddy
was a clown yeah and i i was like i was
like hey
i'll buy you a ring now i'll go buy your
ring now
i was you know you're a young man i was
all over the same word keep that same
energy when weird again
i know and she looked at me and she goes
she goes she goes [ __ ] wow
18 pounds that's the difference that's
how superficial you are
18 pounds that's all it takes huh and
she just walked
yes but it's also like yeah yeah yeah
yeah but it's also like yeah
yeah if i put on 18 pounds yeah some
people look good when they put on it
doesn't matter
some girls some people some girls
there's nothing better than what i'm
waiting for
some women look better when they put on
weight some women look better when
whatever your natural body is
like i know a girl there's a girl who
got the heard the booty done
right the brazilian sometimes that can
look fantastic you go to miami and
everybody's had it done sometimes
if you've got the bone structure if
you've got the thighs that go with it
but sometimes you don't have the thought
you don't have the bone structure it's
like two
ways my problem with guys my size you
take steroids and get you get big but
you don't look big you're still going to
look
muscular but skinny it's the same
problem and everyone can see it you
smell different you have
pains in your neck yeah
it's the same thing as when somebody
who's older gets
just this done just that and then you're
like
oh dude i meant to tell you since you
got your lids done it's like where's
brian
you look exactly the same so
let's not do that anymore because you
look
like yeah i looked at the mirror and i
was like i was like wow
he came in here he gave me the day out
he was all on fire
his eyes were all swung he's like he's
like they say like
two weeks it's gonna be way better two
weeks
do you have to go back nah man i'm never
going back i just got a deal
yeah daddy got a deal on the list all
the lids
that's why i call them lids forever yeah
yeah yeah
rinse is rings stuck big gay owl stuck
i'm i'm never on the road hey ranks big
gay out
they get the more drunk they get i'll
just get a guy just go every once in a
while
every like there'll be a pause in my
jokes gales
they'll crack up and t5k rings
they called you boomer for some reason
as well yeah i did that forever
i
okay so adam pac-man jones uh was in a
bar fight recently that he got arrested
for
he went on uh pat mcafee's
show and talked about it he's saying
that uh
he was arrested and they made it seem
like he was the one who just kind of got
in fight and started knocking out the
bouncer but he said that the bouncer and
his brother got in a fight and he went
in trying to break it up
by the time he got up trying to help his
brother get up from the floor
they started throwing chairs which then
the whole fight ensued and he knocked
out a bouncer he just can't stay out of
trouble man
he can't right he's been out for a
little bit but then he just
he was such 297 he was involved in a now
infamous shooting on las vegas strip
damn he was forced to pay him 11 million
to the victims
what what hold on he's also arrested in
2019
that's just two years ago for indiana
casino who cheated a casino
like counting cards and then upon the
rest jones threatened the police telling
them to suck my dick
he cut a deal with the prosecution to
serve 10 days in jail for one count of
felony cheating
gambling misdemeanor i feel like this is
additionally knocked the man out
knocked the man out in an airport
terminal yeah [ __ ]
he's no joke but i think he's sort of a
player i think i love them as a
quarterback
you can make the argument that this is
head injury if his if i'm his lawyer
first of all nobody hit harder than that
[ __ ] they called him the hitman
right they didn't call him
yeah but yeah take it easy but he used
to run he just [ __ ] he was like short
fast as [ __ ] and just crushed stud
player but just always had some issue
going on
i think he's just a hot head too i think
we're too quick to say ct he's just
he could just be an [ __ ] too yeah
maybe there's that too you know some
guy's just [ __ ] but but
quick to flare up and temper wise as an
attitude damage but he's had this
forever yeah
now he's been playing forever but so
maybe it is how long how long did he
play for
[ __ ] dude he still he was on the broncos
last year he was pretty sure
or a year ago i mean he was the yeah he
was on he was he's been playing
for a while on the colts forever but he
was injured a lot
damn sure and in 2019 so he definitely
wow
on the team last year yeah he's got
money so he was so he he played four was
at 10
so he played for uh [ __ ]
so in 2019 2005's 14 years yeah that's a
long
[ __ ] time so he but he he definitely
has cte
i mean i you know i hope not as a corner
i don't know but yeah no
i don't know but but uh oh he's a lot of
money though he's he's made
when you're a cornerback you get paid a
lot yeah he should have money but you
know 11 million that was a [ __ ] load of
money yeah i know
they just paid to that family wow that
was in 2007 they said
is that is he insured for that how does
that work i don't think so right
dude 11 million [ __ ] 11 million flat
holy [ __ ] what else you guys got so we
were talking about uh your shoes the
other
uh episode and how people thought it'd
look like cake this is
a pair of shoes that look like jamart
they look like cake right
yes jamar and then uh people commenting
under it this is actually
a cake is jamar still boxing yeah he's
still boxing
that's a cake what i want to know is
what is all that stuff those are jordan
1 cakes
yeah wow and it's fondant that they're
covering it all up yeah that's good it
probably doesn't taste
great i heard fondant doesn't taste very
good no it's like
real chewy and kind of tough what's it
called fondant
now that is [ __ ] dope i look like a
shoe why not do the laces out of
licorice
i guess yeah i love licorice that's
[ __ ] crazy though
that's food to show them cutting into it
they should
that's amazing yeah cut into it yeah
no they don't that's how they built it
that's what disappointing it's cool
though
yeah you can't eat it that's dope okay
she give me a regular piece of cake
though huh it's currently snowing like
crazy over
in uh the ukraine and there is a man
whose uh
house was obstructed by a bunch of snow
he couldn't get in or out and he didn't
want to plow the snow himself
so he had the genius idea to call the
ukrainian police and say that
he admitted to stabbing his mother's
boyfriend
and that the body is currently in his
home the only way they could arrest him
is
if they brought a plow to get to his
residence
and he's saying that they couldn't
arrest him like you're not going to be
able to reach me unless you bring a plow
and you plow all this no to get to me
yes he's a genius
police officers did not do that they
just came into suv
and they found him found out that he did
not kill anybody
oh they didn't come out with [ __ ] yeah
they did not power they pulled up in an
suv
he got in trouble but i don't think it's
anything crazy
uh as for the guy you face a fine of as
much as four dollars
for me four dollars four dollars
it might be like the conversion i think
four dollars is four dollars
i did math
yeah it's not like he's rich as [ __ ]
with four dollars yeah true
get a kebab and some yeah stuff
brennan you got this one oh this is
interesting so uh i don't know why joe
buck everyone's getting
crazy about it so joe buck says you know
he's the
voice for like the world series he's the
voice of big nfl games yeah
his dad was a famous uh analyst and so
he talked about how he drinks
during the broadcast like he'll drink a
big bear during the baseball games
because it makes it like more relaxed
and also he said when he drinks beer
it reminds him that all i'm doing is
commenting on a game it's not that
serious so he grabs the bear to remind
him of that
yeah and then he said once you start
working with troy aikman troy man's like
dude you got to cut out the bear you got
to be
healthier so they start drinking tequila
so now you said
all right so he says him and troy have
tequila during the
the games everyone's kind of freaking
out because these guys drink on
on air it's like yeah dude yeah of
course they do they've been doing fine
the whole time right because people are
bored
well they're uh he's you know a lot of
people they can't relate to him because
they feel like he doesn't like
he's kind of a robot i think he's great
yeah
yeah i mean okay so they're having a
little tequila
who gives a get a [ __ ] life yeah we
gotta go after everything
yeah we do yeah we do got something to
do
[ __ ] amazing you can't get away with
a [ __ ] thing
and it's usually just some [ __ ] but
they're on twitter so we have to kind of
listen to them
or do we do we and then they write an
article about it because you got p you
got like
fire online my problem is corporations
listen to this [ __ ] that's what i worry
about
yeah i don't think i think there was cbs
or fox i don't know
i don't think fox i mean we're gonna do
because the guy it's not like he's
getting belligerent and making mistakes
they're two of the best that's what i'm
saying they've been doing fine the whole
time haven't they i wouldn't watch the
nfl fox game if
it's troy aikman or joe buckingham isn't
commentating you wouldn't
you wouldn't are you what do you mean i
wouldn't like if there's someone else
you're a little too into them listen i
like them but i'm still going to watch
the game
joe buck and troy are commentating i'm
out
it's your favorite team i don't care
about malik is a buck aikman free
i go crazy over that voice is so
soothing i love have you heard joel boyd
close your eyes and listen to him for
baseball for baseball he's the best for
baseball he's the best the best
he's so good yeah john smoltz is good
he's good baseball's just too long to
watch but for the times that person yeah
it is
i like i like i like going to the games
and drinking eating hot dogs yeah that's
fun
i mean once every five years that i mean
but i mean
a couple innings oh dodgers in world
series very cool once every five years
one terrified
yeah one one out of five i'm gonna start
taking my kids to sporting events i
think
that'd be a good thing to do whatever
you got to wait in line
the whole ordeal it's a lot it
just give me just give me movie theaters
i'm sitting in [ __ ] traffic
yeah yeah yeah hey but dodge saying hey
man you guys won the world series can we
relocate somewhere
yeah do i have to go up the the [ __ ]
i hate that i hate that look
the hills in los angeles you're a
[ __ ]
huge metropolitan city some would say
the biggest
one of the most important get an airport
that [ __ ] works
well they're doing construction on it
that'll last
taking too long it's taking kids to ugly
airport
it's the uglies it's the worst airport
that weird that weird thing in the
middle used to be a restaurant the sky
lounge
get out of here but if you go to some of
those new uh terminals like you think
it's southwest
and maybe delta with the new new dude
they have like steakhouse sushi
southwest lemonade that terminal i still
think it sucks
starbucks what else you got
you guys were talking about alcohol so
uh they just archaeologists uncovered a
5 000 year old brewery in egypt
wow oh [ __ ] wow is there any alcohol
though
no but look what it says do you know
what it could produce thousands of
archaeologists have discovered a 5 000
brewery that could produce thousands of
liters of beer in ancient egypt city of
abios abi abidos a biologist
tourism what are the two things they
found vetoes what are the two
foods they found that you could actually
eat
that were over i think three thousand
years old
and did they find them or they just say
you could eat they they found them they
were preserved and they were preserved
because i know you can eat twinkies and
a mcdonald's cheeseburger after like
oh my gosh look up look
when did pompeii get hit with the with
the volcano the volcano yeah
let me let me see this oh this was like
yeah and there's food
there's two foods 79 a.d 79 a.d ladies
and gentlemen so that's 2500 years ago
220
that's forever yeah forever ago okay uh
so pompeii was hit with a
with a volcano and it's just completely
obliterated but you can go there
and you can still see there was pottery
and it basically
covered the city with ash so it burned
people and you could see their shadow it
was
almost like a nuclear bomb right but but
the
pompeo itself was kind of preserved a
lot of the stuff was preserved even the
some of the paintings and stuff were
preserved but they found
in a essentially like a makeshift clay
oven sort of thing they found two foods
what would they be
two foods two foods and they were edible
and the [ __ ] crazy
apples could actually wow what the [ __ ]
if i cut an apple in half i didn't know
i can't in 20 minutes it's brown and 20
minutes is brown
i can't believe bananas avocados right
right what's up he's doing this he goes
like this
during the middle of the show it's not
good everybody
this apple this is you know 79 let me
just tell you
i'm gonna say [ __ ] you're a great
teacher and it's gonna it'd have to be
some sort of bread
not a bread no it's not bread i say i
say
my thing is oatmeal yeah won't y'all
throw something
you said it was in the oven right now
think about what prop people probably
had in pompeii and pop it's like what
goes back like what is something that
that goes back
like when you think of rome when you
think of back then what were they what
were they taking in as
what were they what were they what was
on the dinner table it was on the dinner
table what was on what was that
what was on the king's table it was like
pottery it had like oh like chicken
yeah no pants what the [ __ ] on the
king's table
nobody do you see them they might have
had chickens that one is that
again if i leave a chick-fil-a sandwich
right help me you're saying
y'all haven't said anything i'm throwing
out everything i said pottery i said
like what is this they said oven so so
one of the things is like this in it's
in in nature one of the things is just
in
and it's in it's like you don't have to
do any nuts
you can eat it nuts no really insects
not mushrooms you can eat it in nature
it's there it's already there in nature
and you just got to get it
oh chinese plums yes yes chinese plum
throw something out no what don't you
eat that in nature
which was where so we're talking about
italy right
okay and olive it could be olive oil but
it's not
but okay oven well
it was in a it was in a clay on the side
of it
i [ __ ] you up and i knew i would yeah
but there's still no apples in it
and it's not a soup it's not a stew it's
not avocado it's not uh
one of them exists in nature the other
is all of us have had it
i like it a lot like oh bry like oh uh
uh is it a hummus she said it wine
wine [ __ ] i said is that is it
a liquid you have no two foods thank you
that's exactly what you said
of course it's wine
and then what's the other now this is
hummus it's not like a greek
this is a food no this is this is a food
and it's
it exists in nature it's there
in nature i give up i can
get it how do i get it i can harvest it
maybe maybe that's the way to say it or
i can
i can yeah or i can gather it or well
how would i get
a grain yeah a grain not a gram cream is
it a fruit
to nature and i can i can eat it i can
just
now i got to be careful here's a hint i
have to be careful about getting it i'd
have to be a little a little careful
about kids
it's poison is it honey we're in honey
cheese
two liquids yo i have to i was like
no no no hail with you brian how the
hell
you guys got any [ __ ] that's a lot of
food though
what about wine when i cross the desert
the one thing i look forward to
it's a nice cold glass of honey
it's not a food though it sure is
dude
[Applause]
sometimes a little tricky but yeah he's
too triggered but i said so you know
what it's not
you know what's not tricky sure as [ __ ]
was in a chinese plum or an
apple well no chinese chinese plum i
ain't never heard
of asian pear you [ __ ] a [ __ ] chinese
brother look up china i know who has a
chinese
we had a chinese plum a tree i'm
impressed yeah
all right you got it yeah you never have
it that never happened
you called me a brownie like you were up
in a chinese plumber yeah
there's so many chinese plum trees in
new orleans
um you know how taylor swift is
re-recording a lot of her songs because
of the
do i yeah yeah because well
[ __ ] well here's what's interesting
here's what's interesting i don't care
about her
i don't care hold on now hold on it was
delicious but taylor's story is
interesting and someone bought all her
masters and she's like i own those
they're like no you don't
we own all the rights so she's like oh
cool story
and then she's redoing all of them so
she can own it yeah
and guess all the fans are going to go
to the so she goes don't listen to those
don't buy those buy this and they're six
new songs and all the old songs and
you're gonna go over there where the
artist tells you
and that scooter braun uh justin
bieber's manager bought them
but everyone's like yeah so you're
[ __ ] he's like he already sold him to
somebody else he's like i already made
like 300 million off this
well those songs they'll be eligible for
winning a grammy
not on the songwriting category but
actual the song so the same
songs yeah that's stupid even cardigan
i'm sure i think that album is actually
what is cardigan is that her that's not
a famous song that one's owned by her
that's a fairly new one that came out a
few months ago i apologize yeah
so that's the rules right there if
they're recording with them came out
that's weird
huh weird huh that's strange but not for
songwriting since
that's like obvious you can't do that
right it's tight moved by her to take
power
yeah yeah smart a lot of these artists
now lately they're like i want to own my
masters
i'm i'm going to control oh my god i'm
going to put out yeah so everyone that's
the new one yeah with your stand up if
you if you sell your special
and you want to redo them and just put
them on youtube if you sell it to
netflix you
never get it back yeah they own it they
don't license
they buy it yeah so there's no license
you can do it live
and just kind of put it out on youtube
oops you know yeah if not doing it it's
not promoting it
uh you're never gonna work with them
again don't listen to that advice throw
me on netflix don't
shoot a netflix special and then release
on youtube too yeah cause netflix can go
oh
we're never working well i'm saying what
i'm saying if if it's lost and
they're not they're not promoting it
yeah oh got it if they're not yeah
pushing the special i mean people do
that
they don't can't wait to
um do you know about this controversy
i'm outraged by her getting
[ __ ] canceled but okay so ridiculous
but well i mean she's fighting back
she's she's teaming up with
yeah she's kind of well yeah she's
fighting back
what is she doing she's doing a movie
with ben shapiro yeah
about her life right i think it's about
her life or just maybe something that
she's
she's wanted to do far cry from
mandalorian but good for her
you know it's not star wars it's not
disney here's what gets a little dicey
is
even when she did all these tweets which
some of them and whatever if you want to
be political
be political the nazi one with corona
little extreme
but i don't know if she should be firing
but a little extreme i didn't find it
it was a clumsy it might have been a
clumsy comparison
but all she was saying is that a lot of
these
things start with snitching on your
neighbor yeah and that's not good for
unity it's not and i agree with her
here's the problem though so then disney
knows all this and she had the
transgender thing but then she even went
back on that and apologize she's like i
didn't realize i was offending people
by putting my pronouns our bebop boop
you know she was like
oh she's making you know yeah and she
goes oh i talked to a transgender friend
and they let me know that's not okay i
apologize
so whatever she apologized but then with
this stuff disney was like hey man if
you're gonna stay on you need to
apologize
and she refused to do a uh apology
that's when they fired her but i i
yeah again i wouldn't have apologized
because i don't know what she has to
apologize
for she made a reference to the
holocaust she wasn't belittling jews
she did she wasn't belittling the
culture she wasn't political religion at
all
she was saying that if she has a point
of view on this which is that
some of these these government policies
are
are uh oppressive or are authoritarian
and historically the a lot of these
things do start this way i'm not saying
i'm not saying i even necessarily agree
i'm just saying it's a clumsy comparison
but to fi
i think you know what i should lose i
think she lost her job for her
i think sometimes i think they're
waiting to fire her yeah and they're
like all right yeah
she did what and people are upset
sometimes they go you know we have
we want to go take the story a different
place we want a different actress oh
so it's like it's in here yeah i think
so but it's also
her [ __ ] co-star who is very
left-wing uh
what's his name the other guy he posted
something exactly like
pedro pascoe he was on game of thrones
yeah in 2018 he
[ __ ] tweeted something way more
clumsy he competed
tweeted a uh a [ __ ] holocaust
reference where he had kids in cages
at the border yeah and then he had
concentration no one cared
now that's now those kids comparing
those kids and it's terrible that
they're
they're they're taking away from their
parents you don't compare that it's not
comparable to
jews who are starved tortured well none
of it's comparable just don't compare it
none of it's going to be hard but that's
really cool he didn't lose his job
yeah he's celebrating so you think they
wanted her because he's on because he's
on that
side of the spectrum no we live in a
time if you she's the trump supporter
got it well you know if you so they want
to cancel anyone who's if you're a trump
supporter and you're in hollywood
it's no secret if you're a trump
supporter and you're anywhere now
it's no secret she shouldn't know that
you're gonna lose your job she knew she
had to know that there was gonna be some
background some background so i'm
thinking
yeah [ __ ] yeah no there's gonna be
consequences of repercussions but now
dana's in trouble because what because
so he's not necessarily in trouble but
uh he said something like in defensive
he said leave gina alone yeah and then
and then dana's argument is because they
would ask ariel who's espn
that's where the story is he goes oh
this whatever that kid's a douche
yeah because he's trying to make it
about himself that's what ariel did this
post a very long post on his instagram
i'm with dana on this i'm with daniel
what ariel said like you know he he's
disappointed gina yeah i mean it's my
huge
jews and all this is like this is hey
ariel
it's not about him you don't need to
tweet about every single jewish thing
this isn't about you yeah and he's also
in the world too so you're just
dog piling on gina the interview she's
giving you and [ __ ] it's like what are
you doing
so dana didn't say he didn't mention
about his jewish heritage
he just goes i get kids a douche
basically yeah and if you know the
background between dan and errol they
don't like each other so
of course they just take a shot at him
yeah and then all the so
the you know the wokiest being like
we're like oh dana should be fired
and good for you ariel say oh god get
out of here yeah
ariel ariel does great a lot of fighters
the wrong way i mean ariel
is he's a lot of people getting mad at
him yeah yeah because he's a reporter
that wants to get
he's also a good i mean ariel toby
ferris is a pretty good journalist i
mean pretty good mma journalist i would
say i mean you know
but a lot of people don't like him
because yeah the video calls you on
stuff oh just that so this is just him
saying
because he's saying that ariel's making
about him and it kind of does seem like
he does make it about him too but of
course he's also very offended by what
happened too
but i'll play this clip remember it
wasn't that offensive i'm sorry
for everybody to go in on her i love how
era hawaii made it all about him
it was all about him yeah such a douche
yeah oh that's awesome but again that
he's not anti-semitic he's not anti
he's anti-aerial he hates area he
doesn't like girls yeah he's that
individual talking about the area
there's nothing in the holocaust and i
think there's an argument to be made
there i think
he's kind of a lot of people don't like
it you look at ariel's uh tweet like
geez dude don't be hey hey aaron you
don't have to you don't have to
beat a dead don't dog pile she already
got [ __ ] okay right
[ __ ] over big you're not helping
anyone yeah you're definitely just
your colleagues at espn gave you the raw
rob but that's about it yeah you're not
winning anything they have to do that
too well you know i
interviewed uh this guy aleister
bostwick who who is a a journalist and
he's a journalist at huffington post at
buzzfeed very liberal kind of things
and i said to him i go if you had a
story that if you had one story that
say was positive about trump so if you
said took one thing like i don't know
let's say
you took something like trump's
deregulation policies
and you could make an argument that they
were good for economic business
for some businesses or for certain um
segments of the
economy can't write it they're good for
like you know and he said i would get
greenlit
but this is what happens what's going on
with our media it would get green lit
your editor's not gonna say you can't
write it the problem is are they gonna
promote it yeah are they going to put it
on the front page
how is it going to be for you when you
come back to work the next day when
all your colleagues are cutting their
eyes at you yeah and how long can you
sustain that
if you're the one guy that's trying to
like if you're just trying to tell the
truth
yeah if you're trying to go let me let
me see if i can come up with middle
ground there's
some things i like about the right
something's the left i like about the
left you got to be
all or one when you work for the
huffington post when you work for bus
problem with that now now in the
buzzfeed write something or fox news
writes something or breitbart
writes something i already know what
their agenda is i know i know what the
conclusion is i got to read everything
from the right or the left with a grain
of salt
because you there's too much pressure on
a journalist it used to be you came and
the whole thing was to write objectively
right
you you wrote you you're trying to be
responsive to evidence
and you go well here's this and here's
that i i it's
that's a big thing that's what i also
worry about yeah i don't know where to
look
where do you get your info should we
just read it all over
all over of her all over all over what
else you got jen
remember that girl that stopped the bird
watcher
and she had a little dog yeah remember
that girl yeah yeah so she was her case
is dropped now
because she finished a program that
helped her learn about her actions and
how bad they were
so the judge was fine with that so i was
wondering what you guys think you
dropped the charges
no it's she had to go to that program
and then the case was dropped i don't
think he could do anything more after
i think that's better than tosser in
prison yeah so she had to learn
learn what happened what were the
charges why did she get arrested she
just called
she did a fake republican guy she had a
fake report about saying he was trying
to hurt her
oh just because he's a black guy bird
watching at the party that would piss me
the [ __ ] off
the video is very cringy yeah it's
horrible thank god there's video though
she called a false
reporter she was you she was she was
acting like she was being oh my gosh oh
yeah she was pretty she was terrible
it's bad
that's [ __ ] up man how long i don't
have a lot
i don't have that's a good question i
don't know i don't think but she should
go to prison no i think it's good
she's already been she got educated yeah
yeah it's better to learn from this
better yeah yeah
and uh i mean long time radio
radio host personality rush limbaugh
passed away yeah today oh he said yeah
yeah
oh damn not old he was 70. it was
trending it was trending on
twitter but it was rip but it didn't
stand for rest in peace it's staying for
something else rest and piss yeah you
saw that right
no people hated him yeah some people
loved him but he he died of uh throat
cancer or something lung cancer lung
cancer
30 years damn wow
yeah that's that's not what you want
it's weird people would celebrate his
death
though because of his political views
yeah he was uh
pretty opinionated yeah yeah very
right-wing
and this is the last one so elon musk
was on
rogan again it's a new sprinter yeah he
said that's probably the future for uh
tesla 2 to do vans because it's
it's just way better technology for
solar panels there's more
you know more space so you can just keep
driving
and this the top part it'll open up like
that more space
can you imagine that that's what people
are doing they're basing off the
sprinters
they want to base off the sprinter yeah
because that's what all like musicians
are using now yeah those are luxurious
and they haven't trick them out yeah
they're sick yeah i love it you seen the
babies one
no oh missed that i don't know you're
gonna get that brian
uh 100 yeah i'm feeling like i'm so
scared of the world
yeah like i want a i want something that
can go you'd be van guy's son
but i want my guns i want my food i want
i want my
water purification kit i want my first
aid oh you
you'll be a weird van guy i'll be weird
van guy yeah i want my
my lentils and my rice yeah
oh how about this what so there you are
this this survivalist was talking about
all these guys are buying guns right
and you know in case you know i think it
was in a story what's this this is just
recently yeah
there's like a couple of okay we're good
then all right go what's your thing go
for it
this this this prepper this survivalist
was like you know well all these guys
buying guns and they're
all ready i got i got my error 15 i got
my 30 and he's like
so i can kill deer and he goes that's
[ __ ] so cool guys where's your 22
and i was like what he goes where's your
22 long gun in your pistol you know you
know
and they're like wow we need [ __ ]
firepower that's awesome i know
problem is when the [ __ ] hits the fan
you're not gonna you're not gonna be
able to go out to the woods and
catch deer killing deer and finding them
is a [ __ ] you know what you can
shoot all the time and eat
squirrels and they're in your [ __ ]
backyard so who wants to kill so he has
he has a 22 in case he needs fast
protein
squirrels are everywhere in the city oh
he's a weird guy he's a guy
too okay okay you had to get that off
your chest a little bit i saw you
yeah i got you 22. that's the yeah what
are we gonna box
what do you mean let's go to the next
one uh
i saw this uh this morning apparently
they found
a secret will that larry king wrote on a
piece of scrap paper
and it actually leaves his estranged
wife out of
the will entirely he says it's because
uh
back in the day she banged uh their
son's little league coach
wow last minute cut her out of the will
as he's
dying that's holding the grudge let it
go
wow a secret bank account though which
he gave more than 266
thousand dollars to larry jr without her
knowledge and she's entitled to declare
those gifts void and demand to be
returned
wow how much money do you think so he's
like okay i'm not leaving her anything
because she
[ __ ] my son's baseball coach
everyone's like okay that's cool
years ago that's crazy i mean oh that's
holding on to a question
but also makes sense though yeah but
yeah but as you're dying you're supposed
to
just you know i want to leave money to
my kids man [ __ ] her
she's [ __ ] baseball coaches and
sucking off the little league kids
you cannot smoke
larry king man
the dip is gone though this guy i take i
take it out when papa gets hungry i
gotta take it out oh did you get a
little dizzy or yeah i get dizzy
so now this is a new thing you do you do
the nicotine still i've been doing nick
team for a while yeah
this is all this is nicotine okay yeah
it's not tobacco just naked
patches shout to rogue sponsor boy it
keeps you uh
alert like it's good for your mental
acuity yeah it's supposed to be good for
the brain yeah you know what else is
really good what's that
adderall are you pitching drugs again
remember when you did that wait drugs
yeah he's keeping
you done adderall i've done something
similar i didn't stop
talking for about 30 hours i can't do it
i didn't i didn't i didn't finish my
paper i took in college
someone walked in to grab like a bear
i'm like hey what are you doing man i'm
like jesus let me go
i didn't finish any of my work a friend
of mine takes adderall for
add whatever said try this you you could
use it i go i don't i don't know
you could use it you gave me [ __ ]
half an adderall
i was talking about dude i was doing
this i was swallowing i was like
well i'm this is cocaine
and i want to start a business and
[ __ ] fly the plane and you know what
you're flying
and it's pretty awesome it's well every
baseball players on it is that right
nfl guys are on it yeah all right a lot
of comics i can't do it
because i like it too much oh hell no no
it's the best
do you have something nice bro again
what
you got energy for [ __ ] the next six
hours
you could write a whole business plan
dude i mean he came up with big and
hungry on it
this has been amazing go see bryan
virginia
virginia
19th through the 21st sunday friday's
sunday and they're
doing a sunday i've done that in a long
time sunday makes me sad you'll get to
be sad
jacksonville florida economy zone march
4th through the 6th omaha nebraska funny
bone
uh march 11th the 13th 13th hungry
podcast on
uh aka what weathered worm
the weathered worm is on the big heart
the weathered worm and the asian pear
oh no chinese plum oh yeah i like asian
pears though he's also korean half
korean yeah well he's asian though isn't
he yeah
and irish right irish yeah yeah you want
your asian i mean
he's asian right you wouldn't call him
irish
steve he looks asian gene is the more
dominant gene so yeah i've never looked
at him
i wouldn't do that either no i wouldn't
know you you have a splash of irish yeah
yeah he's got a splash of irish he's
half half hour
he's not half yeah no his dad is 100
irish is he yeah i don't believe that
as pittsburgh irish as you get really
just a white oh interesting oh yeah i
think that was a thing back in the day
irish and asian were like a really big
oh i'd watch that way back i'd watch the
head
so yeah so you see him there's his dad
yeah wow
there's mom and dad right there look at
that wow
yeah he is he's asian he's a tiger mom
she doesn't [ __ ] around
oh yeah yeah he looks like his dad yeah
he does
uh you know what he looks like a perfect
mix you know this yeah
steve the nicest guy what are you
laughing at
her cheeks not him he looks kind of like
an older like a very old jim carrey
am i tripping or what yeah yeah good
call not a bad call all right thank you
now steve steve nicest man in the world
nicest person helps so many cops he'll
fight you
he'll fight you right now he's a hothead
like when he's driving he's like what
the [ __ ] is this guy doing i'm like
jesus yeah
ooh does he drive like an asian like an
irish he drives like an irishman
and and and but he'll he'll fight
like weird he's like you're laughing but
i go you'll fight quickly he goes
i do i have a bad temper i go but you
don't have the tools like you don't
no i don't i freak out again that was
funny
he tried to fight this this russian
[ __ ] cab driver
was smoking he goes um we got i think it
was armenian some you know like oh yeah
and the guy's like this and he goes
uh we'd like to take your cab and the
guy goes well i'm done with my cigarette
and steve goes oh geez all right well
[ __ ] you know and then uh like
five minutes ago can we gotta go
actually because i'm not finished yet
but you know when i'm finished we will
go
and see if he goes well [ __ ] this guy
i'm not taking it and he spits on the
ground
and the guy goes you spit at me and
steve goes hey listen dude
the [ __ ] and steve kind of now steve's
then the guy goes
pop
[Applause]
i guess his buddy he didn't learn a
lesson still hot-headed
i'm in tampa next week that is february
26th 27th
tampa florida tampa improv 26 27th
then cleveland ohio hilarity is march
11th through the 13th
tell nick i say hi uh i definitely won't
do that and then uh spokane washington
march 18th through the
20th it's open uh spokane washington is
open that's a rescheduled date so
all the shows are sold out we're adding
a show to thursday march 18th march 20th
spokane watching
spokane comedy club get your tickets at
f-a-t-k-z
dot-com think boy giveaway for the
helmet still going on
thick boy helmet i'm never wearing my
hair like that again
calm
newsletter and you'll double your chance
to win if you do buy a piece of
merchandise
you just pulled that out of a hat i i
look like a sex guru that's what i look
like you do
yeah yeah it's a bad luck go see
chappelle in kansas city the city yeah
the comedy club
of kansas city uh february 25th what's
clever 27th
it's called the comedy club of kansas
city all right i know right and then
i'll be in austin texas uh march 5th
through the 6th at the
vulcan gas company i also love his type
merge
chappelleacy.com oh yeah thanks for
bringing that today and it's in the car
i know that's what i'm saying thanks oh
someone told me you did
just kidding i was calling your bluff
yeah we love you ryan love you yeah
fellas today i'm rocking the custom-made
uh brian johnson's
my favorite uh all my favorite punk man
hey man we've done this already bro
i know you know yeah
uh travis scott what's up we got the kip
on
we got the supreme hood to get
everything over here okay
i know what we're doing stockx supreme
lady shout out to stockx
shout out to kith all right
so for me for me i like to feel the
ground so i have a very thin i like a
thin
thin sole and i hollow out the inside of
my shoe so i look even
so i have a true height i'm at a true
height and so what i do is i go with
the old school yeah
now did you steal those from these
sampras
yeah dude these are these are actually
from yeah stan martin the tennis player
from the 50s
i don't know he wasn't even a guy yeah
these are these are um for kung fu
they're stan smith's
climbing trees that's stan
these these shoes are dope what's with
the pink laces you got to make them look
exotic they stopped
you well like i got to pee keep them
dirty
all right cool